sind Islamisten die Feinde offener
Demokratien nein wenn es nach Twitter
geht denn twitter hat jetzt dem
stellvertretenden Bundesvorsitzenden der
Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft Manuel
Ostermann den Account gesperrt und um
diese Aussage hier geht es Islamisten
sind Feinde unserer Gesellschaft und
gehören entschlossen bekämpft das
beginnt mit Aufklärung und dem
Maskierung offenbar zu harte Worte für
Twitter ein deutlicher Verstoß gegen die
Richtlinien zur Verbreitung hasserfilter
Nachrichten bei erneuten Verstoß droht
Twitter dem Polizeigewerkschafter mit
dauerhafter Accountsperrung dabei hatte
er nur achmat Mansour Experte für
extremismusbekämpfung für sein Einsatz
gratuliert was ist da los bei Twitter
wie korrekt ist politisch korrekt und
vor allem was sagt Manuel Ostermann
selbst zu seiner twitter-sperrung er ist
uns jetzt zugeschaltet schönen guten Tag
Herr Ostermann
schönen guten Tag ich grüße sie kann man
hierzulande über Themen wie Islamismus
Migration Flüchtlinge überhaupt noch
offen sprechen und diskutieren was es
hier Eindruck
ja unbedingt gerade außerhalb von Social
Media ist es wichtig und ich glaube auch
es ist breiter Konsens innerhalb unserer
Gesellschaft dass wir genau diese
kritischen Themen ansprechen aber es
macht mir schon Sorge wenn wir im
Bereich im Social Media eigentlich
demokratische Selbstverständlichkeiten
nicht mehr kommunizieren können ohne
damit rechnen zu müssen belangt zu
werden insofern gehe ich davon aus dass
das eine einmalige Möglichkeit ist hier
auch noch mal den Appell zu richten dass
die Menschen in Deutschland
selbstverständlich die Probleme
kommunizieren müssen und ich gehe davon
aus dass es sich hier um ein Versehen
seitens Twitter handelt geht die
ampelregierung denn ihrer Meinung nach
offen und ehrlich genug mit dem Thema um
nein das habe ich immer wieder gesagt
die Bundesregierung übt sich aktuell im
Schweigen wenn es darum geht im
islamistische Gefährdungsstufen und
radikalisierungsprozesse breit und
offensiv zu kommunizieren und
Extremismus und das sage ich immer
wieder bekämpft man nur zielführend wenn
man es alle umfassend bekämpft und dazu
gehört eben dieses
radikalisierungspotenzial auch dazu und
es ist nicht zuträglich für unsere
freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung
und auch für unsere innere Sicherheit
wenn wir radikalen Islamisten das fällt
überlassen nur weil wir Angst haben
vermeintlich in eine falsche politische
Ecke gestellt zu werden was nach meiner
felsenfesten Überzeugung völliger Nonnen
sind ist denn hier reden wir über
staatsgefährder und über Terroristen und
garantiert nicht über Demokraten und das
gehört auch genauso in die
Öffentlichkeit kommuniziert wie schätzen
Sie die Situation ein was kommt noch auf
uns zu und sind wir überhaupt richtig
darauf vorbereitet
ja wir werden natürlich aus
sicherheitspolitischer Betrachtung noch
immense Herausforderungen haben denn
auch das gehört zu weit dazu wenn die
Migrationsströme erreichen gerade wieder
ihren Höhepunkt und dem sind wir noch
nicht ordentlich gesetzlich gewappnet
und immer da wo viele Menschen in die
Bundesrepublik einreisen sind natürlich
auch Menschen dabei die es nicht gut mit
uns und unserer Demokratie meinen und da
müssen wir hellwach sein die
Sicherheitsbehörden sind das und jetzt
ist die Politik gefragt die
Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen hier
Einführung stationärer Grenzkontrollen
damit wir die sicherheitsspezifischen
Anforderungen auch in unserer Obhut
behalten und wir nicht tatenlos zusehen
wie wir den Kontrollverlust weiter
fortführen sie sagen die
twitter-sperrung war hoffentlich nur ein
Versehen warum halten Sie das für so
wichtig weiter über das Thema öffentlich
zu sprechen
na sehen Sie wo kommen wir denn dahin
wenn wir in unserer vielfältigen
toleranten und großartigen Demokratie
innerhalb unseres Landes nicht mehr das
sagen dürfen was wir sagen wollen und
schon mal doppelt wenn wir nicht das
Ansprechen wo es dann wirklich klemmt
damit will ich sagen Islamisten radikale
Extremisten aus aller collör sind genau
diejenigen die unsere Vielfältigkeit in
Frage stellen und unsere Sicherheit
gefährden und deswegen ist es wichtig
immer weiter diese Thematiken
aufzuarbeiten laut zu sein seriös zu
sein Maßnahmen vorzuschlagen und eins
und das verspreche ich ihm wird
garantiert nicht passieren dass ich mich
davon beeindrucken lasse denn
Extremisten und Terroristen gehören
genauso benannt und das fängt
tatsächlich im kleinsten an und deswegen
dürfen wir uns auch dem Mund nicht
verbieten lassen nicht hier und nicht in
Deutschland herzlichen Dank Manuel
Ostermann stellvertretender
Bundesvorsitzender der Deutschen
Polizeigewerkschaft danke für das
Gespräch ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich
[Musik]